the Joe Rogan experience the last thing
I wanted to ask you about was the opioid
crisis yes and what are your thoughts on
it
this is an epidemic that is continuing
to ravage the country and we are not
doing enough our government is not doing
enough right now to solve it and I point
to to one very simple thing that could
drastically help those who are dealing
with opioid addiction and trying to walk
down that path towards recovery and that
is ending the federal prohibition on
marijuana there has been a correlation
in states that have legalized either
medical use or adult use of cannabis a
direct correlation in a reduction of
opioid addiction as well as opioid
related deaths this is one thing that
Congress can do now to help make
progress in dealing with this opioid
epidemic another thing we've got to put
a lot more resources towards treatment
and on all of the things that need to
happen after that detox that initial
detox with folks who are dealing with
opioid addiction and have lost
everything in their lives then are at
the place where okay well if they have
gotten through that detox now they
they've got no place to live they've got
no place to work they've got no money
and to be able to provide that helping
hand up as they start to put back the
pieces of their life is something that
we as a society need to do better at and
the third thing I'll say is we've got to
go after the culprits responsible for
this when you look at companies like
Purdue Pharma who have intentionally
deceived and lied and cheated the
American people into taking these
opioids saying no you know they're not
risky they're not dangerous don't worry
about it these highly addictive opioids
creating this situation that we are in
they are still not being held
accountable in the way that they need to
this this I think it's the Sackler
family has made ton
of money off of selling these opioids
that have ruined and devastated people's
lives our legislation the opioid
accountability act we introduced in the
last Congress we're gonna be introducing
again soon
would provide our federal prosecutors
with the tools they need to hold
companies like Purdue Pharma and others
responsible for this proliferation of
opioids criminally accountable and
another thing that baffles me is this
constant changing of the dosage this
fentanyl and this new thing that's even
more powerful than fentanyl the fact
that they're developing these incredibly
potent opioids the FDA has approved I
don't understand right I don't
understand why do you need them right
what are they for they're they're tuck
their toxic their fatal and incredibly
small doses yeah and it's not like we
don't already have oxycontin codeine we
have all these pain medications like why
are they insisting on letting these
companies patent these superior and even
more lethal versions of something we
already have a problem with it's exactly
right it makes no sense and I think it
speaks to the huge influence the huge
influence that these pharmaceutical
companies have over regulators and
lawmakers both
so much of this comes back to money Joe